MARTIN: Hello, my
name is Martin.
MICHAEL: And my name
is Michael.
And we co-founded Ubilabs.
MICHAEL: I would like to show
you a brief overview of some
projects we did in the
last few months
with Google Maps API.
So the first one is for Deutsche
Telekom, one of the
biggest telecom companies
in Germany.
They wanted to do a map showing
all the subsidiaries
and companies they
own worldwide.
The special thing about this map
is and how we used Styled
Maps feature to integrate this
Maps features perfectly into
their CI and into
their website.
The map is full-screen in the
background of the website.
All elements are floating
on top of the map.
Of course, you can click for
more information on the
subsidiaries and on
the locations.
The other project I would
like to show you is
Leerstandsmelder, a website
showing vacant buildings in
the city of Hamburg.
We have the situation here
that we have a surplus of
commercial real estate and a
real shortage of residential
real estate.
And with this website, we wanted
to track or to show
this problem in the
city of Hamburg.
The users of the website can
contribute by putting listings
and photos on the map of these
buildings they find the city.
And our goal is to maybe
change this policy when
government officials or citizens
see it on the map.
Thank you for watching.
MARTIN: One thing I like about
the Google Maps API is the
amount of features you have.
MICHAEL: What I like about the
Google Maps API is to connect
the real world and the
digital world.